lucky is a process where you move to
like a newt a clock and you say come on
luck I keep you not so when you are free
man when you have love when you have
help you are again in Paradise he's the
CEO of a Swiss luxury watchmaker he was
previously successful in rejuvenating
the Blanc pen and Omega brands which are
currently owned by swatch his leadership
in the Swiss watch industry has
single-handedly been credited as saving
the industry from the quartz movement
his young close be fair and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
rule number eight is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the fast and as always
guys as you're watching the videos if
you hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
also as you are writing something down
it's much more likely to stick in your
head to enjoy
I love gives them energy we've loved you
go to the ever if you don't have love
which means passion or the algorithm
passion is love if you don't have
passion things are difficult to achieve
in life except Norvin without passion
you are in the normality you are like
everybody you are like a dead fish in
the road Dex is in the road swim with
the current and in the direction of the
current and in the speed of a fish that
is a life go left right give the current
or is the cousin so without passion
you are dead fish if I tell you that we
have 75 schools and that each time the
watchmaker is finished - cool cool then
he should doing one tenth of a second
only finish I love my job
and he told Mexico I love this the next
I love the customer by the way I love
perfection in 75 time he is going to say
I love my job I love my car I love my
book I love my clip I love my life he
will leave 75 phrases and love and we
shut down the case the movement is
inside the 75 traces of love are there
the universe of passion is open to
everybody but many people don't know he
believes passion should come down from
the from the sky no you go to find your
passion
I should will not come to you is like
luck luck cannot come to you you can buy
as many lot of things you can make bets
on barcelona and madrid luck will never
come to you
but you go to luck that's much more
secure you go and go to take luck if you
are stating luck comes down to you
forget you will die and no luck will
have ever come lucky is a process where
you move to luck a new take luck and we
say come on luck I keep you know and you
take another one tomorrow and so on
today especially staying into today's
environment where we have so much
competition where speed is so important
we need we definitely need to always
think different in my company we have
very easy rule whatever we do whatever
in any field we always try to be the
first and all to be unique and all to be
different and whatever the project is we
have to put the three conditions and the
project leader or the guy who brings the
idea has to answer those three questions
if he says yes we will be the first yes
will be unique yes will be different
it's finished there is no budget anymore
unlimited budget no restriction he can't
go ahead because whenever you are the
first and different and unique you
cannot be wrong you will with when you
have a downtime like if something didn't
tear the way you want what you do to get
back on that positive I talked to the
mountain I have a mountain next to my
hope that it's called Worcester delay it
goes up to two is raised hello goes up
to 2004
either oh I talked to the Delta VD which
is 4,000 meters which is really further
away from my house which I see every
morning I see those two mountains and I
say to these two mountains mountain I
have a problem well but when I look at
you you are 37 million old and I have a
little guy and a little guy with a
little problem can you help me they will
say come on look what we have already
seen so many years people problem is an
unknow problem come on get up just get
out never that's it
many people are what we call managers or
fuels and today they can spend seven
years in the watch business and
eventually then they might move and be
few in a car business or in a crystal
brand you know and these people are
clever and great entrepreneurs but they
are not necessarily deeply connected
forever21 passion I am connected just
two watches I don't I would never like
to do another job of course I have other
little passions I love wine I love
cheese I love classic cars but I would
never transform them in a business
because my passion is not deep enough
while watches is my life if I want if I
have to die I want people to remember
two things I want my children and my
wife to remember my love and I want
people to remember my contribution to
the watch business so that's really my
objective that's why I would never leave
this business
and not many I have been in the business
since 1874 so it's really food years 13
I guess in the same business and I don't
know many people in this business but
have been 39 years there some great
people came but they came from a car
brand or came from Ferrari or Maserati
and going to watch business and they've
been seven years they're going to move
and go to hermas or rito so it's
different I am a watch fan what's freaky
it's not enough if you get help you must
accept help and to accept help
you must be capable of learning and who
teach you how to learn nobody the
schools are giving you every day a spoon
of knowledge and you get it in and
tomorrow another spoon and then you
leave University but you don't know how
to learn because you have been used that
they feed you with knowledge but after
the university then you have to start to
learn you have to start to learn how to
love and you have to be humble and you
must never believe you know it you must
have doubts the doubt is your friend
anybody we feud with little doubt I'm
afraid of because these are the
dangerous people people who drive the
car with no doubt in the fog or in earth
on the street full of snow I'm afraid of
I want people that are that have full of
doubts because the doubt helps you to
stay humble and help you every day to
ask yourself am I on the right track
what I did yesterday is that right
my vision is my vision still okay and if
you forget to ask these questions daily
one day you will be in the wrong
direction
so innovation creativity at the end of
the day is more powerful than knowledge
yeah
knowledge is so easy for anybody to get
of course you have to study you have to
learn but knowledge is there whenever
you want
with the new technology whatever we're
all the universities knowledge is for
everybody here and where is innovation
we're in creativity innovation and
creativity is above knowledge that is
what you put on top of knowledge and
thanks God innovation and creativity
people normally cannot learn that gives
the huge advantage to the ones who are
innovative if everybody could learn
creativity if everybody could learn
innovation we would have to invent
something more or different to make the
difference between the people who have
learned something and the people who are
innovative so innovation creativity is
definitely more powerful is much
stronger than knowledge creativity and
innovation is a way of thinking and in
order to make people become innovative
we have created around in our company a
madness Fair that brings people to be
innovate and the most important
atmosphere is that you must permit
people to do mistakes if you give bonus
for every mistake then people make
mistakes but they make mistakes with a
huge pleasure because they get an
additional pay an additional money for
every mistake and when you ask people to
do a lot of mistakes then people become
very active and they trust they start to
trust themselves
the problem is in many companies people
are afraid to be active they are afraid
to take initiative they are afraid to
innovate because innovation brings
uncertainty when you innovate you never
know
innovation is like a vision it's not
reality
the reality you have to make it true
later and that to bring people to take
risk to be active you can only bring
them to that stage if you are capable of
forgiving mistake and how can you show
that you forgive mistakes you give a
little bonus for every mistake and I
promise you every if you do that little
border is 100 to 1000 Swiss francs for a
mistake if it's a very big mistake big
most bonus to small mistake small bonus
so you see it's also a very innovative
way of bringing creativity out of
everybody you blue came out with a
product in 2000 in 1980 a product that
was based on an innovation to introduce
ruble as a struck it seems very common
today but rubber in 1980 was a real
courageous move it was even the
propagation people say hey on a gold
watch ruble because people didn't know
rubber come from a tree remember natural
rubber is very comfortable it's very
flexible and rubber is very resistant
and it's waterproof so finally it's
ideas for what but in those days if
people thought it's a provocation it's a
and then people could not evolve they
stayed on a product and I said we are
not a product we have a message for
we have a concept and the concept is
fusion why because in 1980 when we put
gold together with rubber we created a
fusion because golden rubber never come
together they were together only one
time in life during the Big Bang then
everything was in one and then rubber go
it went away and said ok I go now on my
tree and God said ok I'll go and rest in
South Africa under the earth and since
then they never met till people take
them and connect them so I said a blue
made of fusion and fusion must be our
message must be our philosophy must be
our religion and once we have this
religion clear and it is main fusion
then we can develop further products
that not necessarily need the rubber
anymore because fusion goes further away
than just rubber it can be carbon it can
be ceramic whatever so I was capable to
free you blue from the product and give
we blew a message and from that message
new products were born and that was the
most important element in the revival of
the brand it to take it away from the
product concept and to give it a Brad
method and from the brand the message
where then later born in 2005 new
product this guy from that company told
me you're going to work one year Lisa
beaver and I give you a half a salary I
said what half a salary 50% ash is why
I'm going to tell you because you will
not work during one year you will not
work you will learn and because you
learn
somebody must teach you and we my
company is going to teach you so you pay
me
half of your salary to teach you this
way the good bosses that's the right way
to think that's what you have to tell to
the young people you come to me during
one year I give you a half salary
because the other half you pay me
because I teach you which is true by the
way that's how it is what the young
people they don't want to have salary
they want full salary okay then I don't
employ you stay outside go to another
company young people must be ready to
accept half salary and they are not
ready at least not in the few countries
I know so this guy told me half salary
and no office no secretary no visit card
no phone no traveling no nothing but
what will I get you gonna learn and to
learn you don't need the office and to
learn you don't need a secretary and to
learn you don't need a phone and to
learn you don't need the credit cards
and to learn you don't need the name
card so I started to learn and if you
had yeah I was there learning and how do
you learn when you go in the company
they put you in an office with the
director of the design and then you see
you are there then you sit and the guy
designed watches and he says ok allow
sit there and then you look at the guys
designs and after 2 hours ago or
whatever I do here I cannot look this
guy designing all the time so you start
to ask questions and then the guy says
sorry I have no time at much because
like my watch Nega tell him do you want
the coffee he say yes and then you go
and make coffee you start becoming very
very humble and you don't want to lose
too much time so you try to take from
him to take knowledge from him and then
you tell him yeah for lunch do can we
have lunch together
they say no not now I have my wife
yeah but maybe one day he said okay
let's see and then you have one day
lunch with him and then the guy starts
to become more open and one day you say
ah can I invite you with your wife to my
home and so so I have been wandering the
company sitting with everybody with the
director of production with the direct
of the after sales service with the
director of the Quality Control with the
director of the design with the director
of IT with everybody with the financier
we I read the say with everybody and
because of this I learn the basics of
the history of the company but also at
the same time the history of the watch
making art and after one year I knew
much much much more about the history of
making watches about how to make watches
about the mentality of the watchmakers
about the history of the Swiss
watchmaking industry than anybody else
because I had been one year just
listening to people I had the passion as
a child which was to play with key
machines and one day I believed that I
should take the steam machine and I
should see how this tea machine as an
adult can be present not anymore
like a steamship but like a watch so I
made the transition from the steam
machine to the watch and then the watch
has become my toy as an adult toy of a
try steam machine toy of the adult the
watch and from that day on I entered the
watch industry and I was free of work I
became a free man that didn't have to
work anymore so when you are a free man
and when you have love when you have
help
you are again in paradise I should call
myself paradise man
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Joe Bordeaux
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are going to
profile next leave it down the town's
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you take
from jean-claude today that had the
biggest impact on you what message hit
you the hardest that you're going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or business leave it down the comments
below and I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Janina Lee Del Rio thank
you so much Janina for picking up a copy
of my book your one word
I really really appreciate all your
support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon
I did a lot in my life just because I
got a lot of help health is all you need
and help how do you get help
the first help is love love is all you
need it's a song from the Beatles all
you need is love and the day you die and
you have given love and you have
received love then back there you can
say I was successful that's the only
measure of success is how much love have
I given to other people that's the
success of that life we are here for a
little period and during this little
period we have one mission to share
sharing is an act of love try to share
try to think a mother shares her body
with all of you nobody here in this room
is not the result of a sharing process
between your mother and yourself if
women would refuse to share their body
to share their blood to share their
oxygen no body would be born anymore so
we are the result of a shaving process
the result of love and that's the rule
of life and that's all what matters